How can the nutrients in food vanish in
air well apparel Sunday constitute a whole
meal what is research doing about upcoming
food requirements another bountiful harvest
made possible by industrial improvements in
fertilizers insecticides and farm machinery
and my application of industrial techniques to
farming it seems our storage bins can't expand
fast enough to handle the increasing amounts of
food produced by a decreasing farm population
yet here in the midst of Plenty there are experts
who predict our record birth rate may soon outrun
our abundance threatening America ultimately
with shortages already plaguing much of the
rest of the world in massive efforts to meet
this challenge industry already has found food
where earlier generations didn't even look the
substance being tested in this laboratory is an
example oil from the lowly cottonseed once burned
as waste cottonseed now is a considerable factor
in the American diet yielding vast amounts of oil
for such things as frying salads and shortening
but oil is only one of the many forms in
which we now use cottonseed a byproduct
that turned out to have many byproducts
of its own the long list even includes
nutritious loaves of bread the flower
this batch contains was derived in part
from cottonseed hulls discarded every year
by the thousands of tons not so long ago
cottonseed bread of course has only a limited
market but quite the opposite is true of rice
the major food for more than half the world's
population unfortunately most of the nutrition
is in the outer husk of the rice not in the
kernel itself and thus through the centuries
most of the food value has been thrown away in
the process of preparing rice for the table until
heavy research investment by American industry
taught us how to solve the problem by converting
alternating applications of vacuum pressure
hot water and steam are used to force nutrient
and flavor elements from the hulls into
the kernels and to seal them there thus
by the time the milling and polishing
begin the holes that are lost in the
process already have given up the good they
contain why did industry spend so much time
and money to improve rice the investment
was made to raise living standards while
realizing a profit the same motives that
produce most of the world's improvements
the dream of a day in which we can get all
our food requirements and pills hasn't yet
come true but vitamins in this form have been
mass-produced for years by the pharmaceutical
industry which is able to create synthetically
nearly all the known vitamins essential to our
nutrition it is now possible to manufacture
vitamin supplements synthetically for less
than it costs to grow the plants that provide
them naturally the synthesis of sugars fats and
proteins is a much more complicated problem but
considering the rapid progress of the chemical
industry it's believed the day will come when
a good many of the foodstuffs necessary for
life will be synthesized from their original
elements and put up in pills at the factory
another more immediate new source of
food may be found in arid Texas where
the mesquite tree is being harvested these
days for its protein and mineral content
long despised as a nuisance because its
roots absorb moisture that otherwise might
nourish range grasses mesquite turns out to be
a pretty good cattle feed itself when properly
prepared truck mounted choppers convert it
to manageable form right out in the field
after about a week of caring in the open air
the harvest has moved to a mill on the rio vista
ranch to be shredded into mesquite meals which
then is mixed with grain and other ingredients
the project began during a regional drought that
burned out the range grasses it was during the
search for a substitute for those grasses
that experiments revealed the presence of
proteins and minerals in chopped Mesquite
then being used as flowerbed compost ranch
owner seee Doolin whose frito company in
Dallas turns out more conventional food
items decided the new approach to cattle
feeding deserved a try and the idea paid
off in daily savings that extended after the
drought had ended on the Rio Vista mesquite
meal continues to provide the bulk of the
roughage this ranch uses in livestock feeding
molasses is still required in the mixture but
it's the mesquite that takes the place of hay
in the other common fees scientists say the
weedy plant once regarded as a menace provides
nourishment roughly comparable to that of such
popular livestock feeds as Johnson grass thus
while there's no thought that human beings will
be eating mesquite directly it does provide human
food by helping in the production of beef as
long as livestock remain our best means of
converting some otherwise in digestibility
riyals into nourishing food industry keeps
looking for more efficient ways to supply
those materials and this Springfield Ohio
plant of the Buckeye incubator company
is in the thick of the search its newest
contribution being the grass machines we
see in the process of manufacture at this
stage sheetmetal is being formed to serve as
culture tanks that will hold trays in which
fresh grass can be grown hydroponically that
is without soil in just six days all year round
insulated panels for the housing of prefabricated
so that each unit can be assembled easily in the
neat economical productive package that provides
a constant artificial climate with the help of a
thermostatically-controlled electric heat pump
now let's see how the grass factory works first
in plastic buckets perforated at the bottom to
permit easy draining the right amount of seed
is measured out for soaking this process will
last about four hours after which the seeds
will be removed to the culture trays through which
water and nutritive chemicals circulate constantly
a 60 tray unit uses about 200 gallons
of water per week and the results are
startling as these samples show
and lift a seed at Wright the
growth in six days or to look at it in
another way this grass is one day old
here's the second day
the third
before by the fifth day the grass is nearly ready
and by the 6th it's just right for feeding to
dairy herds nourished by water chemical and
fluorescent lights with no soil involved the
grass reaches 9 or 10 inches in just short of one
week easily removed roots and all the product of
the grass incubator is used mostly to supply dairy
needs early reports indicated encourages enough
increase in milk production to more than outweigh
the cost while freeing much pasturage for other
use 120 square feet of the incubator will do the
work of some 20 acres it's a new achievement of
hydroponics a technique also being used to grow
some vegetables and one that offers even greater
promise for the future even greater promise
for the future is predicted by many experts for
experiments like those underway at the University
of California here another kind of farming without
soil is yielding tiny one-celled green plants
called algae which grow in tanks filled with
sewage as soon as the sewage enters the treatment
tank bacteria in the system go to work on it
converting the organic wastes into carbon dioxide
and water in which the algae can thrive the algae
help purify the mixture by producing oxygen as
they grow to keep the cycle going endlessly it
was discovered that constant agitation or stirring
is required so the Theology are frequently exposed
to sunlight a key factor in the process obviously
hand stirring is impossible in tanks big enough to
be practical so doctors Clarence gelec and William
Oswald added electric pumps ever since progress
has been dramatic leading to conclusions that the
system not only will purify waste but also will
produce oxygen as well as large quantities of the
algae which happen to be high in nutritional value
many problems remain among them development of
an economical way to remove the water from the
algae meanwhile this centrifugal model adapted
by the researchers from other uses is adequate
for experimental purposes by spinning
rapidly like a milk separator it takes
a large percentage of the liquid content from
the mixture leading the water away through an
outer rim contaminated by organic waste only
a short time ago the water now is pure enough
for many uses so a partial solution to water
shortage problems also may result from this
research in a field also being investigated
in the laboratories of Industry but our chief
interest right now is in the algae now ready
for further drying under the warm California Sun
scientists have learned that algae contained 40 to
50 percent protein and large amounts of vitamin A
when thoroughly dry they can be handled in the
form of cakes or chips which when ground can be
fed directly to livestock even using present
crude methods of preparation it's believed
algae meal can be produced at a cost comparing
favorably without a conventional forage crops
while giving us a four fold improvement
in food value per acre of land utilized
to examine one of the main reasons for the new
urgency and hal-g research our cameraman paid a
visit to the laboratory operated by General
Dynamics Corporation of Groton Connecticut
here researchers have devised the prototype
of a system in which the growth of algae will
manufacture oxygen and get rid of carbon
dioxide in sufficient quantities to permit
extended voyages below the surface of the sea
or in outer space an incandescent light tube
15 times brighter than the Sun provides simulated
daylight to keep the process going a process that
someday may provide space travelers not only
with oxygen and waste disposal but with their
food requirements as well another experimental
approach to space food is under study by Republic
aviation at Farmingdale New York under bell
jars the rarefied air of very high altitudes is
simulated in an effort to determine the least
pressure required in a green house built for
inhabitants of the moon just one more of the many
ways in which industry works constantly to make
sure that we will always have enough to eat on
this earth or even above it far out in space